أكثر المقصورة وحدة في العالم بعد أن
نجت من 100 عام تقريبًا ،
تم إنشاء هذا الحريق المنسي Outlook في ثلاثينيات القرن الماضي
للتحذير من حرائق الغابات في المنطقة
التي أعاني منها بالفعل مع الخوف من المرتفعات ،
إنه شيء
يمثل مشكلة مستمرة بالنسبة لي على ما أعتقد
لا أعتقد أنه من الممكن
التغلب على المخاوف ، أعتقد أنه يمكنك تطوير
علاقة أفضل معهم
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنه لا يوجد الكثير من
الأماكن العامة مثل هذه التي
لا يديرها كيان رسمي
موجود  وأعتقد أن الناس يتمتعون
بامتياز القدرة على الذهاب واستخدام
[الموسيقى]
أشعر وكأننا في ميدل إيرث ، فإننا نتعمق في
[موسيقى]
بشكل أساسي في منتصف الطريق يمكننا أن
نرى المقصورة لأول مرة وإلى أي مدى
لقد كان الأمر كذلك بالفعل وكانت ركبتي اليمنى
تستسلم بالفعل ولكن لحسن الحظ أنتم
تعلمون أننا لم نكن نمتلك بيئة جماعية إيجابية للغاية
تشجع بعضنا البعض ،
لذلك اعتقدت أنني قد أستمر في ذلك
وأحصل على شيء من هذا
بدلاً من الالتفاف  حول أ  و
أشعر وكأنني فشلت
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى] أجنبية
سأقول أنه بعد ذلك لدي الآن
مثل هذه الرغبة الجديدة في القيام بذلك مرة أخرى ،
أفهم الآن لماذا يدمن
الناس عليها ، أعتقد أنه بمجرد أن تفعل ذلك
مرة وأنت تنجح وتدفع نفسك
جسديًا ، فلديها هذا المردود المذهل
في النهاية الذي أعتقد أنه يسبب الإدمان ،
فأنت تعلم أنه يجعلك ترغب في العودة مرة أخرى
والعثور على جبل آخر لتسلقه